[Musique]
au moment d'enregistrer cette capsule le
nouveau brunswick ne compte aucun décès
dû à la copie de 19
la quasi totalité des personnes
atteintes sont rétablis est ce qu'une
diderot xi chloroquine aurait sauvé le
nouveau brunswick
plusieurs publications qui circulent
dans les médias sociaux laissant
entendre que le nouveau brunswick a eu
davantage qu'ailleurs recours à
l'hydroxyde le rock in un médicament
commercialisé entre autres sous le nom
de plats cnil ce qui expliquerait le
très faible niveau de contagion dans
cette province
cette hypothèse et fausses et sans
fondement c'est entre autres la vie du
docteur gabriel girouard
microbiologiste-infectiologue de moncton
questionné par notre collègue nicolas
steinbach
selon lui le bilan positif du nouveau
brunswick serait plutôt dû à un ensemble
de facteurs d'abord l'implantation
rapide et précoce des mesures de
distanciation physique la plus petite
taille de la province la plus petite
taille des villes de cette province un
pourcentage lubat de voyageurs
internationaux et l'implantation très
rapide des tests de dépistage tout aussi
rapide
quentin l'hydroxyde chloroquine une
dizaine de patients néo brunswickois
seulement ont participé à une étude
portant sur ce traitement
je répète une dizaine de patients c'est
tout et l'étude a été mis sur la glace
après deux semaines en l'absence de
résultats concluants
santé canada s'inquiète du fait que
certaines personnes pourraient acheter
directement de la chloroquine ou de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine dans l'espoir de
prévenir ou de traiter la maladie causée
par le nouveau coronavirus dans un avis
de sécurité du 25 avril
santé canada mettait en garde la
population contre les effets secondaires
de ce traitement en attente d'un vaccin
la façon la plus efficace de se prémunir
contre la kobe 19 et donc de se laver
les mains et de pratiquer la
distanciation physique
l'article complet de nicolas steinbach
au sujet de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
nouveau brunswick eux se trouvent sur le
site web de radio-canada
n'hésitez pas à consulter notre groupe
facebook et à regarder notre émission
les samedis dimanches sur ici a dit
allez salut
[Musique]